le canada n'est qu'au tout début de
l'épidémie de covile 19
vous voyez donc vous retrouver parmi les
personnes atteintes
la ministre fédérale de la santé a
indiqué que de 30 à 70% de la population
canadienne sera atteint du virus dans un
délai plus ou moins long
si vous êtes une de ces personnes est si
vous connaissez quelqu'un qui a
contracté le virus
et que vous avez des symptômes il est
fortement recommandé de vous placer
volontairement en isolement pour ce
faire il faudra vous assurer d'avoir
certains produits essentiels qui vous
seront fort utiles lorsque vous serez
isolé à la maison d'abord il faut avoir
à portée de main si médicaments et
ensuite du papier hygiénique
évidemment s'il n'y a pas de rupture de
stock dans les magasins
il faut également des papiers mouchoirs
des produits d'hygiène féminine des
couches ainsi que des produits
désinfectants
il est également conseillé de préparer
et conduit quelques recettes santé des
potages ou des plats mijotés et d'avoir
des protéines et des fruits conduit à
portée de main ces réserves éviteront
d'avoir à sortir de la maison au sommet
de l'éclosion où pendant qu'on est
malade
une fois que vous êtes confiné chez vous
il est important de respecter certaines
consignes surtout si vous n'êtes pas
seuls rester dans une chambre séparée et
si possible n'utilisez pas la même salle
de bains que les autres membres de votre
famille
si vous devez être en contact avec une
autre personne ou garder une distance
d'au moins deux mètres entre vous on
demande également dans la mesure du
possible d'éviter tout contact avec des
personnalités
demain lundi chroniques dont le système
immunitaire est affaibli et les
personnes âgées
pour éviter la propagation de loges dans
la maison il est aussi conseillé de
nettoyer les premiers portes de
décontaminer régulièrement les surfaces
sans oublier la télé comment et surtout
de prendre son mal en patience parce que
deux semaines de quarantaine
c'est bien plus long que les 72 ans de
préparation auquel on était super en vue
d'une tempête